vor kurzem waren wir in der halo
deutsche schule in zürich zu gast und
haben dort ein video mit claudia gedreht
wo wir das hochdeutsche mit dem
schweizerdeutsch verglichen haben
natürlich gibt es aber nicht so etwas
wie das schweizerdeutsch es gibt viele
verschiedene schweizer deutsche dialekte
und claudia hat im video zürcher deutsch
gesprochen
heute möchten wir euch mal ein paar
weitere dialekte vorstellen ihr seht
jetzt ein kleines video wo sich fünf
lehrer aus der schule nacheinander kurz
vorstellen und sie kommen aus fünf
verschiedenen kantonen in der schweiz
damit ihr mal hört wie unterschiedlich
das schweizerdeutsch in den
verschiedenen regionen klingen kann
los geht's ab genau wie heiße francesca
40 - st alle und rät st galler die heiße
phase
ich bin 28 jahre alt ich komme aus gutes
spiel und ich leide
hallo zusammen ich bin ich bin in der 20
ich komme aus theorie und die
spezialität guten aber er ist samuel
bisky ich muss lange teil und konnten
und die red hot topic ich heiße andreas
ich bin 35
ich komme von kohl im kanton graubünden
und im ausland konnten
ich komme von chur im kanton graubünden
war ich dem brief was ist in was ist im
beruf das schaffst du das schaffst chef
als deutschlehrerin ich arbeite als
architekt
ich schaffe als schulleiter die butter
aus tierischer geschaffen als lehrer
der geister wie gott dir wie geht's dir
kotzte mir gott sei dank jetzt hör mir
ganz gut
mir geht es gut danke mir ganz gut
was machst du hier was mache ich was
mache ich was machst du da blick wieder
begangen go tänzer und choreograf logic
das bier in der beiz probeunterricht in
norcross immer so unterrichten und den
link ist billy wenn ihr deutschland dann
solltet ihr natürlich nicht einen
dialekt als erstes lernen sondern
hochdeutsch unter unserer app sie lang
könnt ihr unter anderem an eurer
aussprache arbeiten dort haben wir
nämlich verschiedene kleine geschichten
gefilmt auch mit jahren schon mir und in
diesen geschichten könnt ihr immer eure
eigene stimme aufnehmen anhören und mit
der aussprache eines muttersprachler
vergleichen
dadurch könnt ihr ein bisschen selbst
evaluieren wie gut ihre aussprache schon
ist und ein schritt für schritt
verbessern
probiert das mal aus die links findet
ihr hier unten und wir möchten uns auch
bedanken bei der halo deutsch schule die
uns bei diesem video geholfen haben und
sie haben auch einen tollen
youtube-kanal checkt immer aus den
findet ihr hier
dort findet ihr kurzgeschichten auf
deutsches und bis nächste woche
[Musik]